when it comes to pick ups Detroit
dominates and it has for years but now
Japanese carmakers Nissan and Toyota are
finally getting serious about the
segment first up the 2016 nissan titan
XD this is a model that hasn't been
updated in over a decade and drivers
have noticed nissan sold about 12,000 of
these last year Ford sells equivalent
amount in about a week or two what's new
well it looks a lot tougher there's
chrome everywhere there's big name
plates and there's massive side mirrors
inside Nissan's putting a 5 liter diesel
engine it's more efficient and will tow
a lot more than an equivalent gas engine
also this truck is American Nissan's
making it and its factory in Mississippi
meanwhile Toyota has unveiled its all
new tacoma a model that hasn't changed
much since 2004 the company said this
iteration was inspired by desert racing
so it's fair to say it's a lot earlier
than its predecessor there's huge gaps
around the wheel wells the entire thing
is taller and boxier there's even a
GoPro mount on the windshield although
Tacoma sales peaked in 2006 the model is
long dominated the mid-size truck
segment largely because Detroit hasn't
made pickups of small in years but GM
got back in the game in September when
it started selling the chevy colorado in
the GMC canyon one thing's for certain
us drivers have seldom seen a pickup
they didn't like and with two dollar
gasps both of the new Asian trucks hit
the market at a perfect time
you